comme chaque semaine depuis deux ans
claude andré 38 ans se rend au service
d'accompagnement à la vie sociale 10s
avs basée dans son secteur à sainte
marie parce qu'il est reconnu
travailleur handicapé il bénéficie du
soutien de cet établissement de
l'association apajh un établissement qui
propose un accompagnement des personnes
handicapées vers l'autonomie claude
andré et déficients intellectuels malgré
son handicap depuis trois ans ils
recherchent un emploi pour sortir de son
désarroi j'ai pas de boulot pas de
maison
je vais chez ge match en main je vais
chez mes parents et
je veux une vie
voilà quelle belle
je forme une famille de moi même mais je
cherche beaucoup de travail
j'attends j'attends d'un 10 d'attendre
sans plus claude andré est souvent
découragés par les difficultés du marché
du travail c'est ici que le sav est
intervient pour soutenir la personne
paie des gens qui au fur et à mesure
avec la succession d'échecs ou de non
retour par rapport à ces demandes
d'emploi peuvent très vite se décourager
du coup ils ont besoin voilà
du soutien du sms leur permet aussi de
voilà de tenir le coup dans cette
attente et puis de réinvestir ces
démarches là c'est à partir de ce que la
personne nous présente de ce qu'elle
nous laisse avoir de surtout de ce
qu'elle nous dit que nous allons pouvoir
co construire avec elle cet
accompagnement pour sa part claude andré
recherchent un emploi depuis trois ans
avec la volonté d'avancer et le soutien
du sav s il multiplie les expériences
dans mon passage et j'ai fait
et la sécurité j'ai fait de l'animation
j'ai fait
tiens scolaire j'ai fait des espaces
verts il fait du magazine et un
range rayon j'avais déjà fait auparavant
monsieur benoit beaucoup de capacités
mais des fois il a du mal à les exprimer
il se sent mal à l'aise face à son
interlocuteur du coup la besoin d'un
temps pour reprendre confiance en lui et
puis et puis se lancer dans la rencontre
avec l'autre la matinée est chargé au
programme il est prévu de déposer les
candidatures spontanées auprès des
entreprises mais c'est aussi l'occasion
pour lui de bavarder et de se confier
mes dernières situations
map ioniens en font autant qu'a été sa
délaissé en quelque sorte pas plusieurs
tweets par exemple les femmes et
le travail
tg impression d'être focalisé d'une
façon étrange et enlever le regard des
autres quand on parle d'handicap un
regard
oui rabaisser la rabaisse à personne ni
réagi je m'économise capable
faut voir ma cape aspect auprès des sols
la confiance en soi est clairement au
centre du projet d'accompagnement vers
l'autonomie le chômage et le handicap
sont des stigmates qui lui renvoie une
image négative de lui même autant de
barrières psychologiques que le sav s
détecte et aident à surmonter le
contexte social déjà pas facile et après
généralement il ya quand même une
méconnaissance des droits inhérents
aussi aux halles en poids des personnes
handicapées on sert aussi d'interface
donc à la fois du côté de la personne
bénéficiaire qui a besoin d'être rassuré
stimulés et puis aussi un travail auprès
des employeurs les informer des droits
aussi qu'ils peuvent avoir en tant
qu'employeur dans le cadre d'une embolie
ou personnes en situation de handicap
claude andré est confiant aujourd'hui la
persévérance porte ses fruits après
plusieurs cv déposés ils rencontrent
enfin directement impliquons soient
handicapés ou pas handicaper jeu pour ma
part
sont tous à la même enseigne et sont
logés à la même enseigne moi je regarde
pas le physique de la personne c'est
surtout les qualités
l'aisance de la personne a parlé on est
dans du commerce ont fait du commerce
dans l'aisance de la personne à parler à
aller de l'avant à les voir les clients
c'est surtout ces qualités là que nous
on recherche un emploi andré-claude un
rêve pour lui c'est synonyme
d'indépendance de nos joueuses sans
argent mais c'est comme si
avant sport j'essaie de tenir le coup
quand même de ne pas lâcher la sphère de
bouger
j'ai fait avoir que je suis motivé quand
même toi trouve un travail quoi changer
ma vie aussi à mes recherches et mon
indépendance
v
2pendant d'au moins 20
l'heure tourne et avant la fin de la
matinée claude andré doit se créer une
adresse mail professionnel pour postuler
sur internet monsieur sirou l'emmène à
la médiathèque un lieu public où l'accès
internet est gratuit et l'accompagnement
à l'utilisation du web est offert là
encore il s'agit d'une démarche
d'apprentissage à l'autonomie la prise
en charge mais sa baisse en revenait
s'arrête
pendant quelques années on peut
accompagner la personne et après on veut
lui donner les moyens en fait de pouvoir
se débrouiller par la suite en venant
ici ça nous permet de repérer les lieux
repérez les gens aussi qui peuvent le
soutenir dans sa démarche et du coup la
prochaine fois on peut estimer que
monsieur veut noyer sera en capacité d
revenir à la médiathèque s'adressait
directement aux personnes qui l'a repéré
pour faire ces démarches peuvent être
moins de
voix comment faire en fin de compte sur
l'ordinateur je ne veux pas utiliser
trop
la matinée est bouclée il est temps de
raccompagner claude-andré à la gare où
il achètera ses tickets pour la semaine
et rentrera chez lui par ses propres
moyens ces personnes dans un premier
temps ont besoin d'être portés étayée
pour ensuite tout doucement on reprendre
confiance en elle et permettre
effectivement qu'elle puisse comme vous
l'avez pu le voir avec monsieur
hivernaux et faire des démarches qui est
de plus en plus ce sont des démarches
qu'il fait seul ils constituent les
réseaux il va dans les entreprises
privées du stage il ya donc à partir de
ça quelque chose qui se passe pour lui
dans une valorisation est aussi dans
comment je veux dire une confiance en
soi en attendant de savoir si ces
démarches de recherche d'emploi
aboutiront grâce à sa volonté et au
soutien apporté claude andrieu gagne peu
à peu en confiance il peut continuer de
s'accrocher et de regarder vers l'avenir